der freistaat einen traum ich ihr leid
der firma diskothek erzähle geschichten
frühen 1702 junge gefühlten paris machen
sich nach japan auf um nach einem
verschollenen mitbruder versuchen
dieser brief erreichte uns während eurer
reise von portugal ihre diese partner
verleiht möglicherweise tot oder
vielleicht noch schlimmer sein könnte
ist vom glauben abgefallen
in einer situation in der die
japanischen christen ob einer großen
verfolgung zu leiden hatten
da das heim hin dass er abgeschworen hat
dass er gott in den schmutz getreten hat
und vom glauben abgefallen ist und jetzt
als japan erlebt wo wir die verfolgung
geraten nun auch vorbringen von der oper
die auf ihrer suche nach ferraris mit
japanischen untergrund christengemeinde
zu tun bekommen
die materie ist dieser film der auf
einem roman eines japanischen katholiken
beruf der texaner für eine rückkehr zu
einem strang in seinem werk werden immer
schon beschäftigt hat da war immer schon
religiöse themen zugetan an jenen tag
schafften die gläubigen frische hoffnung
und ich war neu belebt
diese tradition gehört und ganz
eindeutig auf seilen der fast das
doppelte des projektes nämlich
einerseits eine theologische meditation
über die frage wie man glauben bewahren
kamen unter umständen die watzmann
feindlich findet auf einer konkreten
leben es ist aber etwas wie ein
kostümfilm wenn wir am wochenende die
mit einem amerikanischen viel zu tun in
dem statt produktiv im englisch
gesprochen wird und in dem die einzige
wichtige spiel zwei junge dafür klaiber
und andrew garfield dass ich das ist
nicht wirklich zweifel wäre und
kartoffeln wenig dabei aufzugeben wir
laufen doch gerade der vorn und die
menschen für uns gestorben sie sind
nicht für uns gestalten sie sind nicht
für uns gestoppt
gut diese beiden jungen männer das lokal
auch durch die vielen kehlen viel und
redet die station figuren in einer
situation in der japan aber die
teilweise auch primitiv erscheinen
obwohl es sicherlich zu gewollt ist aber
es ist eine tief dafür dass dafür auch
große kulturelle probleme hat und dieses
reiche von mystik und politik und
kultureller realität mich wirklich gut
auf die reihe bringt und religion
vielleicht keine hochzeit in dieser
merkt weil die wurst herausgerissen nein
weil dieses land ein sumpf ist hier
wächst nicht dass ein fertiger film
geworden
denn das ist anfangs heben könnte aus
verschiedenen gründen aber es ist schwer
zu sagen es wäre ein uneingeschränkt
gelungen verfügen in die frohe botschaft
hier keine früchte trägt ist das nicht
die schulter kirche das ist die schuld
die die gläubigen von ihrer kirche werk
reifen die den ehemann von seiner
ehefrau will meinen
[Musik]